how YouTube how's it going good great
sounds awesome you're having quite a day
okay so here's a fun story for you I was
on the subway today subway for those of
you who are not in New York is an
underground rail system in New York City
that is inefficient crowded taught and
bothersome the makings of something
that's amazing
basically a subway system is the biggest
melting pot of people when you go to the
grocery store and I don't know if you
have this at your grocery store but at
my local grocery store back home not in
New York
they have a sale rack which is a
collection of like old [ __ ] and products
that are kind of strange that no one
wanted to buy and you took of that
shelving unit that holds all of the
weird products and unusable products in
a grocery store and you personified that
it would be a sub any subway car in New
York City so I'm on the subway today and
this man is staring at me
it's not that crowded of a subway train
I was sitting there and there's probably
about like ten other people randomly
scattered throughout the train he's
staring at me and I my hair my makeup is
done because I was getting head shots
done today well I do acting in the city
so I'm on the subway and he's staring at
me and I'm trying not to make eye
contact I'm not trying to light a spark
of something that could be initiated
here so I'm avoiding eye contact I'm
staring at my feet for a long period of
time and I look up and he's standing
over me I take my headphones out and I
look up at him and he he's this African
man that I think is
from any has an accent so doesn't know
exactly where he was from this is
sounding bad no I don't know he's
standing there these are gaunt looking
and he says I like your hair he's real
and I said it's real hair it's the color
is not real and he says oh okay and then
you stand there looking at me in silence
for a little bit so I put my headphone
that basically is a shutdown of any
possible contact from that point out and
then I leaned back in my chair and I go
back to staring at my feet and I just
see his body stand there for a little
bit and then slowly turn back around and
sit down so I'm sitting there I'm trying
to find a song that makes the situation
better and I don't know music that well
so this is impossible task and then I
look over and he's just staring at me
he's going on but this is anticlimactic
because nothing happened nothing
happened
so I'm great at building a story up but
then there's no outcome really nothing
happened I got off the subway in a
paranoid state where I just kept looking
around me thinking he was gonna follow
me off the subway because I am a girl in
the city and I am completely paranoid
based on all of my parents fears for me
of living in the city I just want to
share that with you YouTube how are you
doing
I haven't talked to you for a while hi
gotta go
good to see you bye